but now look at the fake news
imagine somebody's living in africa and
they know somebody with river blindness
and these these activists are putting
out lies to thousands upon thousands of
retweets
and these people have the internet and
what happens when someone says look look
look look it's it's it's it's going to
hurt you the the the the white people
are coming and they're going to hurt you
and they stop taking it because when
ebola when ebola broke out
there were so i know journalists who
went and covered ebola they they went on
the ground in in some of these villages
and people would break out of quarantine
because they thought the doctors coming
to treat them were actually hurting them
and they were all superstitious and they
believed that you could transfer the
curse and things like that
if you have impoverished and uneducated
villages and we are desperately trying
to help cure their elements and educate
them and teach them
what happens when these activists start
pumping out insane lies
rachel maddow's lies when they're saying
that that ivorbackton's a horse dewormer
all of those lies from the media are
going to be scaring people who were
already worried about being manipulated
you've already got you know joe biden
talking about the tuskegee experiments
granted pete said kiki airmen
you know but you get the point and by
the way like the new york times had an
article about the percentage of young
african-americans uh in new york city
who have been vaccinated i think it's
something like 27 or something when they
wrote it it's probably gotten higher
since then
but they interviewed some people and
some people were saying you know why am
i scared of code i'm way more scared
getting shot by the police it's like oh
you know the the news media spent you
know 18 months or so or i don't know how
long but around that probably longer if
you count back out to 2014 or ferguson
telling people to be scared to death of
getting shot by the cops particularly if
you're african-american
uh now you have people going around and
just random people are being interviewed
on the streets i know i'm way more
scared of being chopped by the cops and
i am by covert you know like 700 000
people in the united states have been
killed by covet 19 right
around a thousand people a year are shot
and killed by police officers i mean
it's very easy math to say that covet is
much much bigger risk than police
shootings but i think if you went back
to these journalists who promoted a lot
of police shooting stories and asked
them well why didn't you at least put
some statistical context in there why
don't you do this why you do that they'd
probably say are you minimizing you know
the shooting of black men by police
officers i'm like no i just want you to
report the truth i want you to report
the totality the context it's just the
statistical data that would let people
know like what act what the actual risk
looks like for them because it has it
has a real practical meaning to people's
lives
yeah one of the things we've talked
about quite a bit is that you've got
kids growing up with facebook being
inundated with nothing but videos of
police brutality and then genuinely
believing that
cops are doing this every day they're
actively seeking people out i mean we've
heard blm activists say like oh they're
hunting us down
and that's just not true but i don't
think it's as
activisty i mean maybe it is maybe it's
activists who are watching i i imagine
you're 10 years old you're inundated by
nothing of these with these videos now
you're 18 20 or in college you get out
you go get a job at you know vox or
whatever and you believe it so you start
writing it
but i do think there's a lot of people
when they give you their excuses and
justifications it's because they're
grifters it's because they're like dude
i got two million clicks on that my boss
paid me a bonus
i'm not going to admit i did wrong
right these people are unwilling to
correct the record because
it's the rage that gets them the traffic
now me
i gotta be honest
i think what gets me the traffic is
admitting when i'm wrong i think the
viewers we have are specifically here
because we do corrections and we will
admit when we're wrong and i'm really
strict with timcast.com on like
any change anything punctuation i want a
note saying what we changed and why i
want a record of that so people go go
there can see it
media doesn't do that
i think you've got true believers who
have been indoctrinated and i think
you've got
i think the grifters are on the way out
to be honest
and now you're getting true believers
coming in they've they've eaten their
own you know they've fed this refuse to
the children and that's probably why i
don't get journalists anymore you get
activists well you know there was an
analogy i i did some work for an
organization that was uh headed by
jonathan hayes a social psychologist
there's a really good analogy for
changing your beliefs instead of
thinking about a as a switch like okay i
either believe this or i believe that
it's on and off think about it like a
dimmer right like oh i'm maybe 70 sure
about this thing but you know i can i
can change it to 50 if someone gives me
some new information some new evidence
because it really is about tying up with
your ego and i think you're exactly
right that like when we have response
systems now or like gamified you know we
have a gamified world where you're given
a certain amount of like you know
happy feelings um from taking a certain
position for making a certain stance
from describing the world in a certain
way you don't want to lose those
feelings by saying ah maybe i was wrong
maybe i should change my mind about this
maybe it's a little bit different we've
set up incentive systems that make us
behave in like really anti-social and
like anti-intellectual ways and i think
your practice that you just described is
very healthy it's like you're setting up
a new incentive system for yourself
you're saying actually my viewers really
like appreciate it when i admit that
maybe i you know i was wrong about
something or maybe it's a little bit
different than i thought before my
opinions change um not all the time
but periodically like uh you know
fairly absolute on 2a you know i i used
to be like well there's got to be some
things we can do we need to have
conversations there's urban versus rural
and now i'm just this point where i'm
like everybody gets guns government
should be given guns away for free give
everybody a gun um i'm i'm half kidding
i don't i i i do argue and this is
important why the government should give
away free guns
is that
the right never fights for anything and
and they say you know a lot of the
conservatives are like it's because we
don't think the government should be
providing these things and i'm like well
here's the imbalance
the the left will demand universal
health care they'll demand government do
things for them and then all the
conservatives will do is say
no
conservatives never actually advocate
for things on their own within reason
it doesn't it doesn't have to be about
giving someone something but i'm
actually
taking this from michael malus god we
quote this guy too much um but he said
the left advocate demands universal
health care the right doesn't demand
universal gun access
but i will say the real argument is
where are the republicans coming out and
demanding a repeal of the national
firearms act where are the conservatives
coming out and saying we don't want the
government to do things we want to
produce they don't do that so you end up
with the left constantly demanding
things and taking it and the right doing
a whole lot of just saying stop yeah i
mean i've written a couple pieces
actually for the washington examiner
which is like a dc based magazine that's
right-leaning it's like kind of center
right or right of center um about sort
of the debates within the conservative
movement about where their governing
philosophy should be going in the next
few years and i think for many years the
conservative movement has basically been
tantamount in many ways the libertarian
movement right like their their general
philosophy is government should take
their hands off stuff uh we should spend
less money we should have less
regulations and we should just uh
embrace personal responsibility and
individual freedom
i think there is a rethink happening
about that and in many parts of the
right right now it's not a dominant
philosophy it's not something you'd see
the mccarthy's and mcconnells of the
world embracing but i do think you're
seeing some people in the senate in the
house and a lot of people on the
intellectual right starting to say hey
look uh we can't really respond to the
collapse of the family by just talking
about another tax cut right like right
you know it's not that you should never
cut taxes you should never deregulate
anything but there has to be kind of a
broader kind of social and political and
economic agenda than i think just the
libertarian mottos and it's really
interesting and kind of what you just
said about guns because i think
one one way that gun policy may be
different in some parts of the world is
that they
you know like gun ownership is a place
like switzerland right like people
it's not super unusual to like have
have like training for your firearm to
have a firearm they often keep them
locked up or they get the ammunition
separate or something but like they they
see they don't necessarily see it as
antagonistic to gun rights to have the
government involved in it at some level
whereas here in the u.s the debate's
very polarized there's some people who
just absolutely hate guns and don't
think anyone should own one and then
there's other people who just you know
they think everyone and their mom and
their baby should own a gun but like
they aren't necessarily saying okay the
government should put together uh you
know a really cool training course and
give it to peop give it to kids when
they hit high school in this rural area
where a lot of people own guns and like
actually get
um you know get people's buying and
confidence and get like people who are
not gun enthusiasts thinking okay
there's a way they can use these things
safely and there's a way we can make
sure people have access to them and good
training and and so on and so forth yeah
the gun thing i think is
one of the most glaring examples of
the media lying and having no or having
no idea what they're talking about and
so like very early on in the gun debate
i just would do basic research as a
journalist and i started to learn more
and more and more about how you know
wrong the media was and they're still
wrong to this day constantly saying
things that make no sense advocating for
the ban of things that don't do anything
uh the example i love to give is that in
maryland the m1a is banned as an assault
weapon but the scar 20s is not and for
people who know anything about guns
you'd probably be like that's a weird
thing to do because the m1a is it's a
great weapon but the scar 20s is more
customizable adaptable
easier in a lot of ways i suppose but
just more modern and and better and i
guess depending on who you ask some
people might like the m1a
but the fact of the matter is this is
what you get from media disinformation
you get policies that make no sense and
you get the escalation and the
indoctrination so actually taxes are a
really great idea we talked about taxes
quite a bit i think ian you were the one
mentioning that like early on the first
income tax was like two percent or
something oh i don't know the number i
think we were having a conversation a
while ago and you were like initially
the income tax was going to be like it
was only for the rich and it was only
supposed to be like two percent and they
were like it's just the rich it won't
affect you and now here we are with like
35 to 45 total taxes not just income tax
like i think they say the average person
will pay 45 of their income in taxes
when it comes to sales tax property tax
you know gas taxes whatever food sales
all that stuff and it used to be
none
but what happens is
they'll come out and they'll say you
know we just want this teeny bit you
give an inch to take a mile that's why
the gun the gun rights advocates in this
country are adamant about giving nothing
away because they know that it's just
chipping away at the block and
eventually it's it's all gone did you
look it up yeah it was three percent
1861 president lincoln and that
eventually i believe got repealed to
later get recreated by the federal
reserve in 19 was 14 i think 1913
something like that
yeah i mean there there one of the
issues um where this where this headed
up was school shootings right like
people
i think we had some very high profile
school shootings in the united states
columbine in the 1990s we had new talent
in parkland um it's really shocked a lot
of people's conscience it was heavily
covered in the media and i think it
produced a policy response that was he
was very well intended i think people
were legitimately scared for their
children but now i looked it up in like
a majority of states i think around a
majority or at least half actually
require students in schools to do school
shooting drills like off top of your
head do you know how many students die
every year in a school shooting what's
the number it's ten it's around ten on
average right it's like and how many
students are there
must be must be 70 75 million something
like that under 18. so
you know school shootings of course are
tragic but what's the impact of having
you know tens of millions of kids you
know hiding in the hallways under deaths
being in kind of a war posture right
within their schools even every town
which is one of the gun control groups
did some studies on this and found that
increased anxiety increased depression
and now they're advocating for reform
saying we shouldn't be doing you know
all these all the time because i think
it was a knee-jerk reaction to a highly
charged issue and i think that we've
seen a lot of that during covert 19 as
well which is where people
i think
you know one one of the phrases that
comes to mind is um better safe than
sorry right you know you can't over
protect someone but what i always say is
like
if you're over protecting people from
one thing you could be under protecting
them from another thing right if we if
we install all these measures on
children against something which they
almost
almost completely unlikely they'll ever
face it we may be under protecting them
against things like anxiety depression
you know long-term kind of suicidal
tendencies all kinds of cognitive
distortions about fear of things that
really they shouldn't be all that afraid
of
we're not think you know if you think
entirely about protecting a population
from one thing you can underestimate the
risk from all sorts of other things and
i think reframing it that way might be
one way for us to be able to to rethink
some of these like overreactions to some
of these threats that we we face
historically thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time